ah ouais enfin l'interview oui non ça
sera facile vous avez répondre par oui
ou par non d'accord interview oui non
vous êtes heureuse en ce moment oui je
vous êtes une bonne mère
je suis obligé de dire oui bah oui ah
oui est ce que vous êtes prêtes à
arrêter votre carrière si vos enfants
vous le demander bon on va revenir sur
la question précédente
je pensais que c est une bonne marque
faire tout ce qui est mal vous trouvez
pas qu'on me voit un peu trop souvent nu
au cinéma oui vous avez déjà eu recours
à la chirurgie esthétique
ça vous fait peur d'avoir 40 ans bientôt
déjà pris de la drogue oui est ce que
vous pensez être une bonne comédienne
oui excusez déjà chopé la grosse tête
excusez-nous je pense pas que j'ai dit
sur la gueule sinon ça va déraper a
dérapé
je vous ai tourné déjà des films
uniquement pour le pognon
est-ce que vous avez marre quand vous
parle de vos soeurs tout le temps non
vous êtes déjà eu envie de mourir oui
croyez en dieu
non vous donner aux gens qui font la
manche dans la rue oui il ya encore un
fantasme sexuel que vous n'avez pas
réalisé
oui croyez que quelque chose après la
mort à des propositions tiennent oui je
sais pas je parle en achètent pas non
oui est ce que vous vous aimez oui
est-ce que vous m'aimez oui c'est vrai
en plus alors bien maintenant alors quoi
bah oui c'est nouveau on s'entend bien
voilà c'est comme ça
est ce que vous pourriez donner votre
vie pour une grande cause
donc les gens du coin ou l'herpès
génital par exemple est-ce que vous avez
des tabous à part le silence est ce que
vous êtes vous auriez un flic m'a gardé
est ce que vous méritez ce qui vous
arrive
oui est ce que vous aimez être reconnu
dans la rue est ce que vous croyez la
justice divine
non est ce que vous croyez la justice
des hommes
est ce que vous avez réalisé mon rêve
d'enfant oui est-ce que vous pensez que
vos parents sont fiers de vous oui
est-ce que vous pensez que vos enfants
sont fiers de vous est-ce que vous avez
menti depuis le début de cette interview
quel temps non j'ai pas menti alors
faudrait pas que ça dérape de l'autre
côté
belga chds
m
les minots steve
des foules